hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to run rooms now this is a
horror game and as far as I know there
are rooms and you run and also it's a
good opportunity for people learn that I
say room differently than most other
people so let's go run in some rums as
we run around now this game is some
level of quality to it oh why hey okay I
scooched a little too close to that
picture and it exploded in my inventory
yeah I don't know anything else about
this game so hello ah another room is it
oh do I need to run oh oh okay I don't
like these rooms I definitely don't like
these rooms hello hello ah good oh no a
note if you are here then you in game
alright good to know locked hello hi
something beyond that door oh hi your
big naked guy ouch ouch Gibble's let's
try that again well now we got to be on
the lookout for a big naked guy good to
know this is gonna announce his rival
with the flapping on the food okay
darkness ah okay so maybe I can use that
to my advantage sometime death death and
darkness darkness death ah my favorite
kind of death anybody want to show
themselves nobody in the run rooms
ooh open okay oh okay
unlock that didn't help me at all
turn around what why oh come on
well you're just messing with me now all
right oh this is baloney hi hello is
that naked guy still here
alrighty then I don't know what the
notes mean okey what take key take key
you said take key where was key I got
key apparently okay all right right way
this is doesn't feel like the right way
oh they're wasting my keys Oh God
oh goody gumdrops oh I don't know that
was I just stared at it for a bit
oh hi work lamp why are you here oh man
I'm getting lost in the run rooms I'm
assuming that the place will my foam
fell the place where that running guy
came from that was probably a way out
because it seemed like if I remember
correctly I saw a long tunnel behind him
which means hello okay
just kind of keep running in the run
rooms till I can't run no mo okay
nightmares yeah I'm having tons of them
right about now huh okay so these
blocked off doors must be the edge oh we
got slappy man Oh
slappy naked man is through that door
but I don't think that doors gonna help
me maybe let's try something here okay
slappy oh why would I want to unlock
slappy then oh boy well that don't seem
good all right let's do this
did I open it I opened it are we digging
hold but if I go through here and I
unlock this one I unlock it and then go
oh this then tell me at all
well this is all in all bunch of
[ __ ] yeah I got naked slappy man
behind me I'm unlocking like a man man
oh boy I'm gonna die aren't I yeah if my
phone could stop falling
my phone is literally just falling more
and more every single time something
happened slappy man oh [ __ ]
tits what am I supposed to do am I
supposed to find something in my foot
supposed to find the pictures is this
likes lending me on stop falling yeah
everything is falling now everything has
fell down ah crap
survive I'm trying man I'm trying back
okay all right oh hello all right I'm
gonna slight where am I going there's no
way to know where I've been except by
just open doors
everything is goddamn maze oh I've been
here the open doors have told me where I
was oh I've been moidered
let's try this again so if there's got
to be a magic t'v right oh man why is it
it just sucks me into it I don't know
what it is it just sucks me in I mean I
appreciate getting sucked in at random
but if we could give some context to the
suck all right what is what are you like
it was like some guy's ass
some guy's underwear pretty sure that's
what that was
I'll take that picture are you okay I'm
not gonna I can't close the door after
it's open my biggest curse yeah okay
well slappy man is here but I've already
gotten three pictures like in a row
which is good I guess I don't know good
luck yeah me I got this collection of
private photos keys those do nothing for
me it's a picture of keys I'll look at
it longingly as I try to open a door
when am I gonna have to run in the run
rooms I know I'm gonna have to run real
soon in the run rooms running in the run
rooms is my favorite thing to do don't
turn back well I'm getting conflicting
instructions here turn back don't turn
back no turn back turn back ah man I was
in the land of milk here we go another
picture oh flashlight I have one of
those I'll put it right next to my
flashlight okay I've got all OH
it's a selfie by that guy or me or
whoever I am
oh why right way I don't know it's
awfully indeterminate when the right way
leads into places that are dead ends
I think I'm getting close to where
slappy was slapping Frick
slappy closed in on me slappy closed in
real good I don't know what the
objective here is is it just like run
rooms until you can't run rooms no more
must be what it is right I don't even
know what that is lamp lamp is that lamp
did I get lamp love lamp
lamps great love to love lamp lamp is my
lamp II another one ha the number one
dad oh this is a dream daddy minigame oh
I should have known there's got to be
like one room in here that slappy
Bobby stop it are you slapping slappy
can slappy open doors freak did it whoa
I didn't open these this is a new area
for me I didn't open these oh I did not
open these well I didn't open them I
should've known slappy stop blaming me
for your transgressions
slappy son of a [ __ ] okay there's
another picture great what am I gonna do
with it I don't know why I have these I
don't know what good they are for me if
they even are good don't stop but I'm
not trying to when you got a slappy man
that close to you try not to stop whoa
wow I thought that was legs I thought
that was legs what is this though hey oh
hey hey ho hey ho so what was the point
of the pictures then did I showed it
slappy and be like Oh
stay back demon I don't know at least
they were good for posterity steel nor
Dewas slappy was chasing me a naked guy
running around in a roomful rooms and
then he just gets angry that I'm taking
all his pictures and keys like he spent
a lot of time locking up this plays a
very meticulous and I'm just ruining
everything leaving doors all open didn't
my mother teach me better than that to
leave doors open after I enter a room so
anyway that was run room this game uh
caught my attention because it actually
has been greenlit so I'm assuming this
is just like a demo of what's to come
but kind of fun
got a fun I got it man I mean the
aimless aim was definitely aimless but
[ __ ] good running away from good old
slappy there so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]